[MUSIC]
AMITAVA BHATTACHARJEE: The reason why we
see a total eclipse in the first place is
pretty remarkable.
It happens when the sun is totally blocked
by the moon because the moon comes exactly
between the sun and the Earth
at some special location.
Imagine you're in a room, and you have a light
bulb in a corner, and you're holding a piece
of circular cardboard to
block the light bulb.
You can do this only if the light bulb and
the board have a certain relative size, and
if the light bulb and the board
have a certain distance.
It turns out that the sun is exactly 400 times
the moon's diameter, and also exactly 400
times further away from the Earth
than the moon is.
This makes a total solar eclipse
nearly a perfect fit.
However, there is a difference between
a partial and a total solar eclipse.
In the area of partial solar eclipse, this
blocking will not be perfect and there always
will be a crescent of the sun that you will
see such as in places like Princeton.
You will have to use protective eye gear to
see it because the sun has harmful radiation.
No matter where you are in the United States,
you are within a day of driving to get to
a total solar eclipse belt.
I'm Amitava Bhattacharjee.
I'm professor of astrophysical sciences at
Princeton University, and I'm also head of
the theory department in the
Princeton Plasma Physics Laboratory.
[MUSIC]